so now I'd like to introduce today's
speakers today's featured speakers are
run Seco and Gordon wetstein Ron fedko
is a professor of computer science at
Stanford University he received his PhD
in mathematics from UCLA and did
postdoctoral studies both at UCLA in
mathematics and at Cal Tech and
Aeronautics before joining Stanford he
was awarded an Academy Award from the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences twice the National Academy of
Science Award furnishes and research a
Packard Foundation fellowship a
presidential early career award for
scientists and engineers along with
several other awards he has currently on
the Editorial Board of the Journal of
computational physics and he
participates the reviewing process of a
number of journals and funding agencies
he has published about a 120 research
papers and computational physics
computer graphics and vision as well as
a book on level-set methods for the past
17 years he has been a consultant with
Industrial Light and Magic he receives
green credits for movies such as
Terminator 3 Star Wars Episode three
Poseidon and Evan Almighty and most
recently on Kong Skull Island scorned
wife scheme is an assistant professor of
Electrical Engineering by courtesy of
computer science at Stanford University
he's a leader of the Stanford
computational imaging lab and introduced
the primary research group focused on
advancing imaging microscopy and display
systems at the intersection of computer
graphics machine vision optics
scientific computing and perception
professor West Dean's research has a
wide range of applications and
next-generation consumer electronics
scientific imaging human-computer
interaction remote sensing in many other
areas he received a PhD in computer
science from the University of British
Columbia and graduated with honors from
the Bauhaus and aymara Germany before
that he has won Allen Fournier PhD
dissertation annual Award is the
recipient of an NSF Career Award and has
won best papers at the International
Conference on computational photography
as well as the live all virtual Awards
so both of them are quite accomplished
and I should also mention that they are
cool academic directors of our new
visual computing graduate certificate
which I will talk more about after the
presentation so now I'd like to first
turn the floor over to Gordon for the
first part of the presentation thank you
so much for the introduction Stephanie
that's a really exciting time for visual
computing because there's a lot of
dynamics in both computer graphics
computer vision but also an applied
perception and virtual reality so what
we'd like to do today is walk you
through some of these topics so you get
an overview of what visual computing is
all about
so Stephanie already introduced us but I
pulled up this night photo of run where
you refuse a technical achievement award
- sorry about that but there was really
a great achievement and he's done a lot
of groundbreaking work in simulation
visual effects and is now working on
machine learning as well I work more on
the imaging side our co work on displays
computer vision and more recently in on
virtual reality as well so you may
wonder what computational imaging is all
about and all these topics are about so
so I just want to walk you through some
of these and show you some of the top
trends in these topics so computational
imaging is usually this idea of Co
designing the optics the sensors and the
algorithms for camera and traditionally
cameras have been designed by designing
the optics forming an image on on a
digital sensor or in a film plate and
then just looking at the image but with
the rise of computational power we can
now Co design these things so that the
computer can understand the image and
extract meaningful information so what
does it mean in practice practice that
means a camera today doesn't work
similar to what a camera did a couple
hundred years ago even though it looks
the same
we now capture multiple images with
different exposures every time you we
hit the button and that's called high
dynamic range imaging so most of your
cell phone cameras will actually capture
different images all at once the
processor on the phone will then compute
a single image that it combines the most
useful information from all of these
images and that's pretty much a standard
mode we can also think about super
resolution so trying to resolve features
in an image
are not visible in the resolution
offered by the detector and there are
many other imaging modalities like
extending the depth of field capturing
light fields and doing you know more
exotic imaging modalities like
impressive imaging so so this all sounds
great and how does it translate into
practice what we've seen a couple of
startup companies coming out stanford
and also here in the in the Silicon
Valley such as light roll which build a
consumer electronics version of the
light field camera that you can buy in
the store now this camera allows you to
do things like post capture refocus so
you can take a picture and if you got
the focus wrong you can actually change
it after the fact this camera also
allows you to extract depth information
of the scene which is increasingly
important for things like autonomous
driving consumer electronics gaming and
other applications another consumer
electronics startup company just down
the street here from Stanford is called
light light has started to release a
camera that they called elf 16 has 16
different cellphone camera modules you
can see that here in the middle and they
all have different focal lengths
different properties and they can all
snap a single picture of a scene and
then the computer will I should figure
out how to merge all of these images
into getting a really wide field of view
super high resolution image with
unprecedented image quality my cameras
aren't just meant for consumer
electronics they also enable new
experiences for example in virtual
reality on the right you can see text
books a new 360 camera captures images
in the 360 degree sphere and can then
process these to fuse them together into
a seamless virtual reality experience so
so these it also ties in back to you
know enabling new types of experiences
with these imaging systems for example
in virtual reality so it turns out that
the similar idea can also be applied to
display this co.design of algorithms and
unconventional optical systems together
with focusing on you know understanding
human the human visual system and a
couple of research ideas that people
have been working on are
dynamic range displays super resolution
displays new types of projectors or or
glasses Fritz would you display and of
course we're also interested in you know
developing the next generation of head
mounted displays for AR and VR so I want
to talk about one of these technologies
a little bit more which has already
migrated into the consumer electronics
world and that's a high dynamic range
displays so when I did my PhD about ten
years ago there was a really nice
research project with a couple of papers
things that you've learned in a course
but now you can actually buy televisions
in Best Buy or anywhere else that has
that technology integrated and every
company has a different name for it for
example local dimming is what Samsung
calls it and the basic idea is that you
can modulate the backlight of the
television the LEDs that are actually
inside the television together with the
LCD that is usually being used to create
a contrast that is much higher than what
you get with a normal display so let's
create a much more lifelike experience
and much better better user experience
overall okay so the basic idea between
behind computational imaging is it
probably is this bridge between optics
and modern signal processing
optimization so we mostly work with
geometric optics we we think about
lightest rays traveling in straight
lines and space my research group
offices let us work on using wave optics
and more complicated optical models that
that are more physically accurate but
for the most part in computer vision and
imaging it's good enough to think about
light as rays and then use modern
techniques in optimization read learning
machine learning and so on to design new
kinds of devices such as cameras centers
foot and these have applications in so
many different domains every one of you
probably has a whole bunch of cameras
already in your pocket because your cell
phone likely has at least two of them
but we also think about new and emerging
you know depth cameras for consumer
electronic applications or cameras on
drones we can think about surveillance
medical imaging cameras are in States
they've been used for biomedical
applications in microscopy and they've
been used of course also for emerging
autonomous vehicles or self-driving cars
that where the computer has to make the
decision of what to do next so designing
the sensors for these campus systems is
absolutely critical
so now let's to think about computer
vision a little bit more and how it's
different from imaging the imaging is
very close to the hardware we design
algorithms and Hardware together but at
a very low level computer vision is more
concerned with inferring high level
information of the screen such as you
give me a couple of images of your
living room and the algorithm can figure
out what's the 3d shape and the texture
and the colors are so that we can use
that in for example in an online program
where we can place new furniture in your
room and you can try out you know
different arrangement of your room you
can order furniture from Ikea online and
place them directly into your into your
living room at the same time these
techniques are also useful for
autonomous driving for robotic vision
and for many different other fields but
in general computer vision is concerned
with high-level decision making or
inference on data that is captured with
camera so another topic that comes up in
computer vision quite a lot is scene
understanding so given an image what's
going on right so if we look at the
upper left image here this is a picture
taken from a car the car wants to
understand where the lanes are it wants
to understand you know where other cars
are how fast they're driving on the
lower left we see you know an example of
segmentation we want to understand is it
a pedestrian we're looking at is it as
bicyclist is it it is the driver is it a
building is it a dynamic part of the
scene and so on so segmentation object
tracking object understanding and
recognition these are key challenges in
computer vision and on the lower right
you see a classic example where we take
an image and the computer will figure
out you know which object is what and
try to find it also in a database of
existing objects so for example we can
say hey on the upper left there's an
airplane on the lower left there's a
human and maybe we think you can do some
face recognition on that so these are
all classical computer vision problem
tracking is another one so we want
be able to predict that happen from
emotion for different types of objects
in the sea so computer graphics I don't
want to talk too much about it we
learned a lot about teapots and bunnies
and strange rooms with reflective
objects one will talk a lot more about
this but computer graphics is there the
science of you know taking a
mathematical description of light
reflectance models of geometry of the
team and computing an image of this that
is ideally indistinguishable from the
real world another emerging area is
virtual reality and augmented reality of
course - it's an area that's been around
for a few decades already but in the
last few years we've made so much
progress and we now have the first
consumer electronics devices that
delivers fully immersive experiences and
virtual reality is being used for many
different applications from simulation
and training to entertainment to
visualization but you shouldn't forget
about robotic surgery for example - on
the lower right you see the DaVinci
minimally inversion robotic surgery
system where a surgeon actually remotely
operates the robotic arm to be able to
to do surgery lights either in the same
room or even in a distant in the distant
location and so that's virtual reality -
because the surgeon only relies on the
visual stream of the endoscopes
and at the apex see in in the remote box
which is basically Virtual Reality
Display fundamentally VR is a new medium
that enables totally unprecedented
experiences and we still have to learn
how to use this medium and create a new
types of experiences effectively so it's
a very exciting area of a lot of
dynamics and development enhancing
virtual reality is also one of the Grand
Challenges of the National Academy of
Engineering
so not just from a Content correction
side is interesting but also from an
engineering side because it brings
together computer vision displays human
perception computer graphics and many
other disciplines so you can see that
kind of in this overview slide here as
it's just a whole length in the middle
the whole event has so many different
parts it has custom-made chips such as
CPUs GPUs the central processing unit
graphics processing unit but all the
image processing units we have a whole
array of sensors that do teen
understanding hand tracking positional
tracking and other things we need to
understand human perception and its
limitations so we can build effective
displace and at the same time we need to
create content for example using things
like cameras or computer graphics so
just one I spend one or two minutes on
you know telling you a little bit more
about our research area or one of them I
took bonds Virtual Reality Display so
normally a phone or a small display
inside a head mounted display behind the
lens and your eyes will look at a
magnified view of this image this will
be simply bigger but it also gives
farther away
so each eye will basically look at a
different plane floating in space that's
how you can think about it and then will
be at a fixed distance so the focal
distance of this display is going to be
at once existence and that's not a
natural viewing experience to think
about 3d vision and here's just a one
minute overview really the human
perception is there many different cues
that the human brain uses to interpret
depth from a sea
so there's vergence that's the relative
rotation of your eyeballs in their
sockets it's an ocular motor cue so
muscular cute this is driven by
binocular disparity the fact that we see
two different images with our eyes and
does you need to create with Virtual
Reality displays because we simply
render you know slightly different
perspectives in front of each eye but
here's the challenge the eye also
focuses its crystalline lens and that's
driven by retinal blur which is you know
similar to a depth of field effect in
the USL our camera this is a cue that we
can easily reproduce in a virtual
reality because we cannot optically
correct and sweating the look you easily
all these kids are coupled together and
that's what creates a lot of trouble so
in the real world as we look at
different objects your eyes will verge
towards these distances so they will
rotate but they will also accommodate so
they will focus to these distances so
all these cues are always working in
together in virtual reality this
mismatch between these cues I'll try to
illustrate that here we can render
images so that you converge at arbitrary
distances but the focus of your eyes
will always be linked to that floating
plane the magnified image in space so
the discrepancy between different cubes
that the brain receives is something
that usually creates I stress visual
discomfort nausea and other undesired
effects so I group does a lot of
research in trying to address bits for
example and here's again an image of the
fixed focus display where we place the
phone and behind the fixed distance of
the lamp a couple of simple ideas of
addressing just you know focus issue
would be to either actuate to display by
slightly displacing it inside the
head-mounted display which you know
changes the magnified image distance
another way would be to use
unconventional optics that can
dynamically update the focal power of
the lens and this is a very effective
way to change the magnified image
distance and drive accomodation of the
human observer in practice we need to
use eye tracking for our head mounted
display so we build it very simple
prototype that you can see here which
has a stereoscopic eye tracker and a
motor mounted to the focus adjustment
mechanism of the gear VR okay so this is
the prototype we can basically change
the motor very quickly based on the
track acquisition of the viewer and with
only a few millimeters of mechanical
displacement we can actually change the
focal plane of the display by a large
amount over the entire range of which
you can focus so that just gives you a
little bit of an overview of what
virtual reality computer vision and
imaging is all about
we teach it classes on all of these
topics including virtual reality you can
see photographs of Stanford's II
267 class so this class is focused on
you know helping students to build a
head mounted display from scratch over
the course of one quarter and with this
I'd like to hand over to Ron who can
tell you more about special effects
computer graphics and some other topics
in visual computing
let me start before you and get into it
and just mention there's a reason that
Gordon and I are talking about a little
bit more in depth the two topics we're
talking about because the Hollywood
effects in VRA are is it graphics
traditionally there's a lot of small
things going on in graphics which have a
lot into the back but there's been sort
of modes of graphics that everybody sees
in your house which people typically see
our movies and games so the two things
so we think about it and look at all the
movies and all the technicals into that
I think at George Lucas Star Wars Pixar
a lot of graphics was driven from that
the other things all the video games if
you look at the ARD are that sort of the
real-time aspect of graphics from the
games and supporters continuing in that
direction with not only the talk today
but also his research program and
similarly for the Hollywood
special-effects that's something that
I've been pushing forward for the last
20 years I'll talk about that a bit in
the beginning and then what we're going
next and that's also part of the reason
that Gordon Eyre is sort of running the
center is we're sort of looking at the
future of graphics and where's going
it's important whole when you're
thinking about this like what you want
to do with visual computing that you
realize there are these two big driving
technologies which are real time and not
real time or movies and games in that
sense and they are research to talk
everything represents that and in some
flavor there's a lot more look into
later so I have this very general Venn
diagram to get started it just shows
that the Hollywood special-effects now
is sort of mixing in a lot of different
things you've always had rendering
graphics geometry and graphics animation
and graphics that's always been there
and more recently physical simulation
has come in that's something that has
come in the last 20 years and even more
recently computer vision is playing a
much bigger role and the machine
learning we get into as we go so going
back to my lab we've done for 20 years
it's digital simulation you see it in
many movies or some examples
Davy Jones Harry Potter etc etc and when
doing physical simulation for movies
what we focused on is many many degrees
of freedom water wrinkles and cloth
waves on the water smoke vortices that
sort of thing
you really want high visual fidelity
very rich details but what that comes
from is computational physics there's
nitrous copes equations for the water
there's finite element models for the
cloth and so we look to all those things
in order to do the simulations but if
you look into computational physics what
you find is that your algorithms are
really good for finding the drag on a
wing or the lift on a wing or modeling a
scramjet engine and vaporization of
drops they're very very um accurate or
faithful to real-world data and that's
not we want for graphics we want stuff
which is sort of hyper real in that
sense so competition of physics is a
motivation for what we do but it's not
just taking the equations from consurtio
physics and re implementing them in a
graphics pipeline it's doing something
different with them
there are last 20 years I put half my
papers and computational physics and
have my papers and graphics in my boring
PhD students 34 and 10 current they've
really struggled along with me to look
back and forth between those two
different areas and target simulations
and methodologies towards those areas
and it turns out it's very very
different
you can't pick up stuff from one and put
it in the other or vice versa and that's
been something that's really helped us
lead the field in this area is
understanding you know what goes where
gave me new idea is that an idea for
competition or physics or an idea for
graphics if you have something in
physics does it working graphics there's
a not looking graphic and vice versa and
that's been that's been the essence of
my research program for the entire 20
years I've been in it is just
differentiating carefully between those
two areas with with each idea no round
peg in a square hole type stuff you have
to avoid that so more recently say two
years ago I started realizing there's a
third area of simulation which is very
very different from what I had been
doing and it took me a while to even
realize that even though I spent 20
years differentiating the features
building technology from the competition
physics technology putting about 50
papers in each one but it started to
sink in a little bit and the idea was if
somebody went out and filmed some cloth
or film the way
on the ocean then you wanted to somehow
use those waves in your simulation to
get better-looking water or water that
look like a lake or an ocean or a
bathtub or whatever it was
and use the data or you you know scanned
in some cloth you saw how it moved you
wanted to use that or for human tissue
you know if you took a bodybuilder
scanned in and muscles and with how they
flex they do a simulation of
biomechanics and the muscles you want to
be faithful to that how would you
actually do that and I originally
started out doing that with what would
be number two on this slide it took the
constitutional physics approach to be
faithful to the real-world data I pushed
in the biomechanics for a while and did
with what they did there but it turns
out that the biomechanical stuff doesn't
really lend itself well to the data and
so it took a while but we started to
realize it really is a third paradigm
for physical simulation which is popping
up and this isn't just true for
computational physics as far as like
smoke water fire and cloth human body is
also true for rendering and in other
areas think of them not as um just
physical simulation which is simulation
in general anytime you're synthesizing
the real world
you want to think about different ways
of doing it you're either trying to be
faithful to the real world which would
be the compositional physics or you're
trying to have something really cool
like a game or a movie that would be
that the feature films type stuff on
this slide or you really want it to sort
of have the look and feel of the real
data so we started looking more
carefully into data statistics and
machine learning and the first thing is
data data is what's really driving this
there's more and more data everywhere
wherever you look people are collecting
data storing data internet pushing data
around and it's more and more data start
showing up they get better ways of
collecting the data and the better way
to get collecting a data the more and
more data to get statistics and machine
learning and obviously the areas that
work with the data actually statistics
you would think just the statisticians
work with data that's been a job for a
long time
the thing is statisticians never had
that much data so in theoretical
statistics it was really way too talking
about dealing with small amounts of data
even today you know if you look at a
political poll they polled thousand
people and that's supposed to represent
what you know tens or
millions people would do well why not
pull a hundred thousand people or a
million people that would be much better
but statisticians worked very very hard
at using tiny amounts of data to
represent large populations but the
world is changing now we have large
amounts of data we can we can get a lot
more data and they're not really taking
advantage of it it's a speed one
wouldn't expect if you look at math
departments going back historically once
computers start taking off these new
mathematicians start showing up
they weren't theoretical anymore they
were applied mathematicians there were
numerical analysts computational physics
white people and it was sort of a new
way of thinking about the world through
the computer as far as mathematics went
as opposed to the way it was done
through pencil and paper in the past and
once you had a computer you had things
like an Merkel linear algebra numerical
optimization miracle Odie's and PDEs
the new mathematics has to bring out of
this similarly is we add all this data
the statistic if they never had you're
going to need a new way of dealing with
statistics and what's happened which is
kind of neat from from my standpoint as
computer scientist is that people in my
department Daphne Koller and earning
Sebastian's run they sort of you know
picked up the ball on this and started
taking all this data and the computers
and everything else and developing this
new area which we now refer to as
machine learning machine real machine
learning people are really the next
generation applied mathematicians that
are coming out of Statistics departments
because of the data similar to the way
the applied mathematicians come on to
the math departments because of the
computers going back in the past so it's
really draw me towards machine learning
and which is part of the artificial
intelligence groups in fact on Tuesday I
formally joined our AI lab at Stanford
so the new part for me you know that
machine learning people have been really
knocking to ball it apart for five ten
years now and then in part for me is
looking at all this stuff through the
lens of physics because they do
simulations and so he looks through
things to let the physics as opposed to
sistex things a little bit different for
example um here's a good example suppose
I had 10 balls and I took each ball and
I dropped it
you know from shoulder heights to the
ground and I measured how long it took
to go to the ground and I try
and measure the acceleration due to
gravity and suppose nine volts fell with
speed 9.8 in one ball hovered in midair
statistician might say well okay it's
about 9.6 gravity on average it might
say no no that one's an outlier let's
get rid of it it's about 9.8 a physicist
might say holy crap have all floated in
midair what's going on so it's a
different way of thinking about the data
which is like looking was actually
happening with the physics as opposed to
statistically kind of waving your hands
and saying you know it's noise it's
outliers this and that it's looking at
the date a little bit differently a good
examples incompressibility for example
they have a bunch of data and it doesn't
represent any compressible flow I know
that data need to go through some filter
to make it incompressible as opposed
just saying there's noise outliers or
other things these are often called
priors and machine learning and many
people use these priors but it's sort of
an advantage that you have become from
physics to look at it and something
we're trying to do in our group so again
just to summarize before I show you a
few examples the goal of our research
these days is in Thunder lining the
bottom is to design new numerical
algorithms that better allow for the
incorporation of data into the
simulations themselves make things super
real not just a cloth simulation for
movie which is really nice but super
real and pulled from real-world cloth so
some projects the first project that got
into it was fate simulation and you know
I've been at Stanford for 17 years full
professor you know I've been here for a
while so not a lot of things really are
over the top and present I've seen all
the impressive stuff for 17 years and
you know you tend to get a little
callous or a little bit more relaxed as
time goes on but this idea really hit me
there was a Wednesday after Thanksgiving
and we had this idea for muscle
stimulation for the faces and my grad
student trivia Ian implemented it and by
that evening he showed me a simulation
with a face it was better than anything
I'd ever seen before
by a quantum leap and the big thing we
did was we took a bunch of data of faces
moving around and we designed a
simulation system that could actually
target that data so in the past when we
did simulations you know you'd flex
muscles you move them around
but whatever your biomechanically
accurate physically accurate but what we
did here if you learn how to target the
actual data and it really made a big
difference in fact we already use it in
King Kong Skull Island we had the idea
wrote a paper in less than two months
was implemented in less than 12 hours
paper in less than two months and it
went in the movie production it'll be
right after that and within less than
one year we finished an entire movie
with it from idea conception to
completion and it really a huge
difference in the movies we did building
models for a long time this is it maybe
a 15 year old picture now for my
graduate students that we flew up to
Canada and covered in latex and built
some high-resolution muscle models using
the old matrix technology from the
Matrix films to remember that these days
is easier you can just scan in a statue
with the scanners we have much better
graphic technology now until the face
model trying to face model out of that
we output these with finite element
models you know by mechanically accurate
muscles all everything you would imagine
and we use cameras and pure vision in
order to track what what faces do in the
end then you have some model for out
face moves typically using a lot of this
you can build an exterior shell model
which is on the left but you're just
trying this moving around but using some
of our new technology you can take a
skull and put it inside that face on the
left this is what the right picture is
or the skull underneath and put muscles
underneath the skull and flex all the
muscles in order to try to make the face
to form in order to match the thing on
the left so on the left is just a a
sculpt made by a modeler it just went in
and used some animation software to move
around all the triangles get really
nice-looking face on the right is a
muscle stimulation which is supposed to
mimic that they look statues are very
similar very similar but there's some
small differences for example look at
the lips on the left there a little bit
washed out a little too smooth and on
the right they're a little bit more
vivid and we capture that bit more vivid
because we use the simulation stuff
underneath I'm going to say okay it's a
small change why does it even matter the
reason that matters is the sculpt on the
left was supposed to be perfect an
artist made
with gold standard and it was something
we used in the effects industry
is it perfect and then we ran one muscle
stimulation on it one time just to check
it out to a target that data and we're
like wow the lips could be better we
actually don't have a perfect thing it's
actually much improved one thing we
struggle with an effects industry with
humans is we make them more and more
real there's something called uncanny
valley we're all telling something is
too real it's disturbing if it's not
completely real there's a gap there
between things getting better and
getting all the way and so when you get
to this gap you have to be very careful
you typically pull back and make the
Hultgren or change things a little bit
so it feels less real so you can accept
it does that take a completely real
human it changes just a little bit for
example you know put it in a casket
that's pretty scary right or a zombie
you think about that kind of scary so
these things that are almost real but
not real they're very disturbing they
don't work well in movies and so we're
trying to get by is uncanny valley if we
knew what was wrong we just fix it this
is an example where we know what's wrong
the thing on the left we thought was
perfect but it turns out the lips could
be better we learned that from the
simulation so we can make it better and
this is the main thing we want to
address in the movie industry right now
using this technology which is can we
make the faces real and get through the
uncanny valley to the other side here's
a video that shows some of the other
benefits of this though in the upper
left is a bunch of sculpts done by an
artist the triangle mesh moving around
in the middle is the result of the
muscle stimulation targeting in every
frame just like in the last slide in the
far right you can see the skull and some
of the muscles moving around underneath
the the middle to show what the skull
and muscles had to do in order to target
with the simulation which MUX here is if
I if I take the far left model which is
a bunch of triangles and I build a skull
for it on the far upper right and
muscles and I can figure out how to
target the animation that have some
knowledge of how things are moving which
aren't just triangles so if I take that
Yoda statue we scanned it on the lower
left and I fit a skull of muscles to
that then I can take the upper right
skull and muscles and that that one the
ones
lower-right skull muscles and move them
around and it can use it to animate the
scanned in diode amesh without any
artists help or any animation or any
packages or anything it's really just a
muscle simulation going forward making
your do stuff existing technology we
take a triangles from the upper-left map
them to the triangles on the lower left
iota and try to push things around but
which is a fat lip on the guy in the
upper-left compared to yours very thin
lips you'd actually see a fat lip moving
around on the ODE and it wouldn't look
good there's not a good one-to-one
correspondence between the facial
geometries of the yoda and the guy in
the upper left but the muscles
underneath have a fairly good one-to-one
correspondence because we're all
actuating things the same way and if I
actuate a muscle or open my jaw or smile
or do something like that that looks
different than every person but
everybody is basically trying to
activate the muscles in the same way and
so you get a nice one-to-one mapping
it's much better than principal
component analysis or any of the other
methods because more physically driven
so another project going to talk about
is cloth this is one of our very big
ones we've been doing cloth simulation
or lab for a long time these are
actually 10-year old pictures of cloth
and all the details have been on to
collect clocks used a lot in movies
frozen like a cartoon example of using
cloth and the you know Yoda in Star Wars
a good example is robe of a more
realistic version the thing is the real
world has much much better cloth in what
we see in movies if I go into a movie
theater and shut out all the lights and
turn on the sound and tell you a story
and show you the cloth on Yoda you might
say yeah it looks real that looks like
real cloth for me but you also think
yield is real and Yoda is not real
obviously but somewhere during the movie
where it was dark with the lights out
and you really wanted to believe your
suspension is belief you actually
started thinking Yoda was real so it's
very easy for me to make a pretty crummy
piece of cloth if you're real - you -
you want it to be real but you want the
order to be real that's the advantage we
have in the movie theater but if I going
to ecommerce or something and want to do
some cloth on your body you're not going
to want to see something that supposedly
real and doesn't really fit you return
it to the store after you order it so
there's really a gap between the movie
cloth where you're willing to accept the
cloth where you want the cloth to seem
real and the cloth that you act
would have an e-commerce to show how it
fits on your body something you could
buy reliably online know how it's going
to fit shift to your house where how to
fit that way and be happy with it not
return it to the store so this is
another place we want to use data we
want to take real world cloth scan it
all in get all the data from how it
looks how it folds how it behaves and
stuff it into the simulation so we can
do simulations of it we can learn from
it and have it actually represent what
would happen so you could you know scan
and eat a body model of yourself move
your body around have some virtual cloth
on you that moves and folds and act just
like the real cloth moreover if I can
actually mimic the real world of cloth
and get this data into my simulations I
can go back to Yoda and make a robe on
him which is so super real that you
could even make it in the real world and
it behaves the way the real world does
but it's even better than the real world
that's what we really wanted the movies
is something which is hyper real and
even better but if we can't do the real
world cloth it's going to be tough so
what we're doing in the cloth right now
is um at the very early stages but we're
already learning a whole bunch about it
for example if you look at the figure on
the right here if you have a curve and
the curve represents a scan of a
real-world cloth as a lot of folds is
the black curve and I down sample it's
something I can simulate on the computer
which would be the blue curve then
notice that geodetic distance gets
shorter the length of the black line
between two of the blue points is longer
than the length of the blue line so I'm
compressing all the edges and so if you
build a database doing this you know for
machine learning or or anything else you
scan a bunch of cloth breath it down and
make a function from the coarse cloth to
the fine cloth and then you simulate
your cloth what's going to happen is
you're simulating the coarse cloth
incorrectly and you can't look up the
fine cloth let me explain that with a
projection as an example look at the
checkerboard on the far left if you have
a piece of paper and it's orthogonal to
the camera and you project a square it's
going to show up as a square but if you
bend that thing away from the camera is
going to stretch the square out so in
order to make it actually pure like a
square on the camera they do in this
paper from 2016 you have to take the
edge of the square and compress it if
the paper
is bent and so you have to learn how to
compress things when they're related in
the projection and did a very good job
at that so we need to do the same thing
in cloth if you look at the upper right
here if the rest shape of a piece of
cloth is long and then you look at the
line below it when you compress it it
wrinkles that's what happens is the real
cloth then in our simulation if we only
have one edge there when we compress it
so it looked a third figure down that's
the simulation edge and we compress it
it just needs a shrink it can't bend
gets a single line sent where other
details actually bend it but we want to
be able to take the real-world data of
the bending and wiggling and projected
onto there so we needed to actually
shrink so I project the wiggling back on
there we get so we get the right thing
we can't just shrink the cloth by
relaxing all the springs or finding
elements connected because then it also
stretches too much and so what you
really need is in set up forcing edge
lengths on your simulated cloth to be
equal to the hreflang you need to
constrain them so they can't get bigger
than the rest length and sag like the
lower-right picture but you want them to
shrink less for edge length because you
want them to be compressing we're going
to add the real world data from the
wrinkles later no cloth techniques do
that so we have to go out and design a
new numerical method for simulating
cloth which allows for edge lengths to
be constrained with an upper bound but
no lower bound and so if you look at in
the lower right that's an example using
our new inequality claw with inequality
constraint and if you look at the that's
a fire right if you look at the left
picture that's using the equality cloth
and you can see it's when it gets really
detailed in folds there the Equality
cloth has much bigger folds and some
some buckling and some resistance to the
fine details and wrinkles you'd normally
expect whereas the Equality cloth
actually starts doing the right thing
it can start folding a little bit better
again it's subtle and there's no data
here but it is in the real world you
have many many more wrinkles which would
be superimposing on this cloth the cloth
sorry buckling doing the wrong thing
because you're enforcing the edge length
constraints to be equal which is
incorrect for a compressed version of
cloth then it gets pictured on the left
and you can't put your data on it anyhow
think about it like you have a sheet of
paper and you compress the paper a
little bit and you want to get some
wrinkles well if you think compress the
paper if it state it's normal sized just
added wrinkles to it it magically be
getting long
and adding geodetic distance and that's
something you don't want you know what
to call our officially gaining wrinkles
that's what everyone does now it taking
quality cloth and wrinkles to it so
they're actually increasing in surface
area which looks really bad and and
trained just like a cloth is growing
wrinkles out of nowhere
so this is where pipe lines gonna look
like for cloth basically if you start on
the far right fine results is scanned in
data from the real world then you
compress it which would be the blue
bubble effect of a second from right and
you get the coarse result which is a
compressed cloth and those are the
things you store in the computer now
going to the far left give you your
inequality cloth simulations which will
be sort of course and you look them up
in your database of course results and
then use your machine learning functions
that you've learned or define the find
results from the real world and map to
that and stuff those two things together
the ideas we want to hybridize scanning
a real-world cloth with the best
simulations we can do to get ultra real
cloth I'm going to mention the bodies
for like one second here we're putting
body model together with muscles we're
scanning in weightlifters this is
michael blacks work from europe with
scanning and people to learn about the
muscles we're trying to add muscles to
the body because you want to really
learn how to body works under the cloth
before you do the cloth on top the idea
here is scan the really lean bodybuilder
learn on the muscles work first and then
shrink the muscles down to normal and
add fat on top to get a more normal
person so trees the last topic i want to
address in four trees a trees really a
multi body system you can think of a
tree is continuous with maybe the leaves
is having angles there but as the tree
bends moves around you think it a bunch
of cylinders to multiply systems are
commonly done we've done a lot of those
in our lab for example Davy Jones
tentacles or something that we had done
we can model tanks and skeletons and all
kinds of things as multi body systems
the problem is the tree this tree in
particular which I see on my way to
Stanford every day on my bike is it
that's a lot of bodies all those leaves
all those branches put a little cylinder
in for everything not to mention that
that's just not that's not just a bunch
of cylinders that's an amazing
configuration of geometry but I have to
bend and move into form it's impossible
to do it with a multi body system it's
way too complex
we worked for a long time trying to
build some things especially for that in
fact we made this specialized approach
which allow us to do something really
big
again the idea was driven from you know
real world data we want to actually take
a tree model like this scan the tree and
build the tree simulate the tree
simulate the wind getting the tree and
everything else these the real world
data to drive it so it looks altra real
so building a simulation system for this
was impossible and we had to do some
researches to do that the neat idea we
had in that research was people often in
all these robotic mechanisms build these
approximations to the exact solutions
and multi-body problems we inverted that
a little bit we actually made an
approximate problem and found the exact
solutions did approximate problem
it's got similar errors in many ways but
because it was an exact solution we can
solve it without any of the stiff issues
in numerical ohi's we got rid of
stiffness and time steps abilities and
everything else so if you actually
simulate something with many many many
bodies the simulation was wrong that
we'd never converge to the right answer
you may we made approximations in the
equations themselves but if you go back
to people who approximate the exact
equations they never get there either
and so you can bound the errors that's
not so bad we use this to seem at all a
bunch of really detailed trees this
shows you so much elm trees you
simulated but we hated all these trees
we used the best systems we could to
build these trees who are never able to
simulate them to our liking because of
the fact that we just didn't like the
geometry we really want to simulate that
tree and so we ran to a problem where
you know we couldn't synthesize in
graphics the kind of tree that we wanted
to simulate we wanted real-world data
once again for simulations and this time
we're having trouble getting the
real-world data so we went out and tried
to use 3d computer vision to reconstruct
the tree fact we took drones and cameras
and flew them around the tree and did
all the usual stuff and we started
getting things but you know what we
couldn't get the tree we couldn't do it
what we realized was in computer vision
a lot of what they do is use texture to
make up for missing geometry so when you
look at something you feel like a 3d
geometry server it's not really there in
fact when you look at its picture there
you might say oh that's a decent look of
a 3d tree but actually having a three
tree at all we
you are looking at is a slide which is
projected on your 2d computer screen
it's completely 2d there's no 3d
geometry in any of these pictures
actually nothing I've showed you with
any 3d geometry you look at that tree
there's no 3d geometry there you think
you see something in 3d but you don't
it's projecting the 2d in your eyes and
your brain are doing shape from shading
and other algorithms make that feel 3d
and in fact whenever we do 3d
reconstructions of things in computer
vision and we think we're building 3d
models we look at them on our computer
screen so you don't really have a good
evaluation so it turns out that we
actually need not just new simulations
incorporate the data we need new data
for the simulations typical computer
vision doesn't really construct the data
that you need in order to go through and
articulate the tree up and build a multi
body system that can be simulated it's
good for looking at good replacing
furniture it's good for all these
different things in a rough way but if
you want to simulate all this you know
find out the stress and strain and the
floorboards from your furniture and that
sort of thing or actually put a bunch of
cylinders into this tree had it bend in
the wind and do and do its thing it
takes a lot more detailed geometry even
new computer vision in machine learning
algorithms or just collect the data so
we found ourselves an interesting spot
where we actually need really high
fidelity geometry the computer vision
really doesn't doesn't provide yet and
so we need not only new simulation
technology to take care of the data but
we need new ways of collecting the data
to provide to the simulations and so
it's a two-way thing that's what led me
more recently into the artificial
intelligence lab to work with all these
new appliance mathematicians because we
call machine learning people and the
last slide just on wind inference it's
one of the cool things you want to do
with a tree once we can actually build
the model once you can solve both the
problems I mentioned that you can
actually build this tree and simulate
the tree and then video capture the tree
and actually figure out how the wind is
affecting the tree and pull that wind
off and use it for other trees or other
models or for making movies and that
sort of thing so wrap up there at 10:50
and we'll have 10 minutes of questions
so we want to head into the QA as a
reminder please type your questions into
the Q&A box so that Gordon
and Ron can take your questions but we
do have a couple of questions and to
start so if you guys maybe want to take
the first couple so the first question
is what career skillsets education
training should we be focusing on now in
future for visual computing in the
workplace what do you want to mention
with graphics and visual computing in
general is that people usually think of
visual computing is complimentary to
something else so you should take you
know a bunch of visual computing courses
you know take the ones in certificate
that's why Jordan I picked those is that
give you good basis but we always want
people at something else and so I talked
about all the machine learning in the
data science and that sort of thing it
would be a nice thing to mix a lot of
this with that people also mix visual
computing with like human-computer
interaction HCI classes where the
hackers are mixed visual computing with
systems pipe glasses graphics is one of
those things you visual computing in
general is one of those things where
it's nice to mix them in a hybrid way
with other areas so almost everyone that
comes to me says they want to do
graphics then what they want to do it
for I always tell them to add something
else to it and so I would stick with the
visuals difficut is the core but ask
yourself do I care about systems so I
care about HCI to ensure about you know
hardware people make graphics cards as
part of graphics so architecture or
something but find the other thing and
once you nail the two things that you
want visual computing plus whatever the
other thing is it will guide you through
the visual computing courses to choose
the ones that are most appropriate that
hybridization compositional geometry you
know math leo kiba's proves a bunch of
theorems all the time so we take his
classes and get more into mathematics
that's that's my advice is to always
find the other the other field you want
in addition to visual computing and
hybridize them okay so the second
question is will this technology improve
better and more accurate medical
research of diseases like cancer
diabetes and others so that's a
interesting question visual computing
isn't necessarily linked directly to you
know research in
in medical imaging however a lot of the
techniques that we're talking about in
sensing and computational imaging in the
Applied Mathematics and imagery
construction are also being used in
medical imaging we work very closely
with faculty from radiology department
for example that work on computer
tomography work on medica MRI scanning a
lot of the medical imaging techniques
use very similar principles and very
similar algorithms and even though I
don't think anybody of us is directly
working on cancer research none of the
techniques may be able to help you know
discover new things in those fields as
well I'll take that you scroll a little
bit I think the geometric model one is
there an estimated timeline for
developing the next level geometric
modeling needed to address many of the
challenges explained today that's one
question I'm also going to take the
question does your work involve
convolutional neural networks which is
two down they can answer those together
um last quarter in the spring there were
two very interesting classes taught one
by Leo kiba's on geometric modeling
using machine learning and networks and
one by Feifei Lee and her students on
convolutional neural networks um I
actually took both those classes I mean
I know a lot of this stuff and reading
this stuff but I was in every lecture
anyhow in case or something I was
missing there's fantastic stuff
happening right now
in the field of computer vision on both
3d geometric modeling which is one of
the big things that are needed and the
convolutional neural networks my
favorite classes at Stanford that aren't
visual computing our leo's class I just
mentioned a face class that just
mentioned in Andrew names 2:29 machine
learning class I think anyone interested
in visual computing with data or
anything else should should definitely
make sure do Andrews class fades
convolutional networks class and real
key versus geometry classes but that's
really one of the big future areas of
cvpr
in computer vision is the 3d geometry
and Leo and I talked in general about
putting together simulation and geometry
and how some of the stuff in geometry
which isn't reading it can be improved
with simulation and some of the
simulation stuff already can be improved
with chiama
so is real back and forth between that
travel neural networks are really
finding a basis for things you know you
have things like Auto encoders or
whatnot and you know for a piece of
cloth let's say what is a good basis of
representation for that cloth you could
try doing FOIA analysis and finding sine
waves of the folds or you can do a
convolutional network or an auto encoder
as many ways of doing that but these are
I think two really big things
importantly related to the visual
computing alright I'll take a question
on how to how does visual imaging
integrate with images and vision in
neuroscience and deep learning so a lot
of the classes we teach actually draw
students from many different departments
we have a big neuroscience institute
here at Stanford and a lot these people
actually take our classes as well
because even though visual computing is
mostly focused on consumer electronics
and entertainment on areas like this
again the underlying techniques the
underlying algorithms for processing
images for learning images for using
deep learning convolutional neural
networks and things like that for
learning the fundamental building blocks
and the structures of the images and
what's inside is equally applicable to
other fields and although visual
computing is not focused directly on
neuroscience
the same techniques that we teach in our
classes are applicable to those areas as
well ok that was it was a question on
business opportunities also further up
can you give us some applicability to
business scenarios beyond web rendering
of products so I think visual computing
has a lot of applications in many
different fields that you may not think
of immediately I mean what comes to mind
after seeing this presentation is movie
industry games now virtual reality
things like that consumer imaging but
there's a lot more beyond that a lot of
the students here at Stanford actually
go out and found their own startup
companies or get involved with new and
emerging trends and things like you know
think about virtual reality as something
where's the first
you know in analogue to where the first
phones came out and people started
writing apps for that so it's like a
gold mine almost where you can think of
any kind of an application write an app
and it can make a huge impact that's
where we are now with virtual reality
where people use it for gaming but think
about you know architectural
walkthroughs or virtual furniture
placement or any kind of problem that
you may have at home you can use these
techniques that you're learning in these
classes and in virtual computing to
solve some of these problems and that's
what makes it very excited something
else on that which is interesting so I
have 30 former PhD students and tell
them are doing machine learning ten
innumerable they're bunch of ten in
academia they're pretty split up in
different areas one thing you hear back
from the ones who don't actually do is
much visual computing any more than
within other areas is that it's really
handy to be able to click a mock-up
together of what you're doing with some
graphics and one thing we focus on it's
on the introductory classes at 1:48 it's
just getting your hands dirty with some
OpenGL some ray tracing learning to deal
with rendering geometry in the basics
and they find that for any projects are
doing just the ability to you know to do
some interesting computer graphics is
useful for them in their other projects
and again I talked about the
hybridization between different areas
and how we think of that in graphics all
time you may end up in the other area
90% of the time but if you can do
graphics a little bit everyone you know
is going to want this real thing
together for them and it's just a common
theme that if they think of use a
graphics person you can just do better
better demos of everything and so keep
that in mind too it's really something
to have is just a tool in your skill set
for anything that you want to do so
let's take two more questions and then
we're going to wrap up just in the
interest of time so what do we think
about some other questions here all
right here I'm going to take a question
how soon can we expect a R&I hololens
and other things to substitute personal
computing effectively I think this is a
great area of research right now and we
see a lot of transition into useful
products we see we are being used in
gaming it's being shipped with the
PlayStation Micro
announced that it's going to ship one
with Xbox and there may be other game
consoles where it's useful today Apple
recently announced that iOS 11 will
include a lot of functionality for
augmented reality but that's going to be
mostly phone based I think AR as you
think about things that are integrated
in your in your eyeglasses and give you
in display and a window to this digital
world completely replacing other
computers that's still going to be 10
years out or so and that's a very active
area of research right now but I
wouldn't I wouldn't expect this to come
in the next two years or so okay I think
we're actually going to wrap up after
that question and I want to give a big
thank you to Gordon and Ron both for a
wonderful presentation for taking time
to answer attendee questions as a
reminder the recording will be made
available within a week and sent a
participant we want to thank you for
taking the time to attend today and we
will see you at the next webinar thanks
so much